US President Donald Trump is threatening
to declare a state of national emergency
to get enough money to build a wall
along the Mexican border
Trump is angry that Congress has only
approved a quarter of the funds he wants
for the wall 1.4 billion rather than the
5.7 billion he had demanded declaring a
state of emergency would give him direct
access to funds the bill approved by
both parties in Congress avoids another
government shutdown well for more on the
latest developments in Washington we
have Erin Collier with us here from Bard
College in Berlin good morning Erwin so
another government shutdown has been
averted it looks like but president
Trump is going nuclear as it were by
declaring a national emergency in order
to get the funding to build his wall
will he get away with it well you can't
fault him for not trying he he really
wants to make an end run around the
constitutional power of the Congress to
control the purse strings and this is
what it's all about he is not getting
the money directly through legislation
he wants and by trying to put this up
with the sort of crisis like the swine
flu or the 9/11 attacks he is hoping to
not have to go through this cumbersome
cumbersome negotiations with another
equal branch of government he wants to
be able to write his own checks and this
is the attempt he still doesn't have the
land to build such a wall so you know
there are many things that go into
building a physical barrier not least of
which is having the land this is a
long-term project and this will not be a
long-term executive order how do you
read these maneuvers that were
witnessing in Washington the signing of
the border bill getting the budget
passed there to avoid the government
shutdown and Trump then declaring a
state of emergency a national emergency
do they these maneuvers expose Trump's
weakness order they show him to be a
clever tactician
it certainly shows we've seen the
behavior before he does not apologize he
never admits defeat and in the middle of
a wholesale retreat he is declaring a
victory and organizing parades this is a
par for the course we've seen it before
but yes he's been completely rolled the
Republicans really got bloodied up with
the last government shutdown anything
but that
and now the amount of money the strings
attached Donald Trump knows he lost that
round by declaring a national emergency
the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi says this
is a this is something we should we
should look at very warily she says it
could create a precedent that could
create problems do is this a threat to
American democracy well what's
interesting in 1976 after the Watergate
affair the Congress thought about this
what happens if we get a scoundrel like
a Richard Nixon or possibly something
worse
this declaration of an executive order
and the ability to say when the dick the
executive or this executive power is
surrendered no no the Congress said they
have the power to say enough is enough
and what we'll see is immediately first
thing Pelosi will bring a resolution it
will pass in the House of
Representatives disapproving of this 18
days the Senate then has to take a
position very good chances that that
gets a slim majority also disapproving
so the law to end such a power grab will
be on Trump's desk he would probably
veto it but we don't know that yet and
then it's back but then there's the next
line of defense which are the courts and
the courts have not been kind to such
initiatives on the part of the Trump
administration a lot to keep track of
there in Washington at the moment or
when thank you very much for filling us
soon or when Collier from Bard College
here in Berlin
nice to be here